la fois où j moment ça se passe toujours
bien aujourd'hui c'est le giraumon elle
parfois c'est la pastèque parfois c'est
la patate douce les shoots chine enfin
on fait ces types d'opérations c'est
pour aider les agriculteurs locaux
et puis aussi aider les ménages
les bourses de ménage c'est vrai qu'au
longjumeau
on apprend tout d'abord dans la soupe
oui oui d'abord dans la soupe
et puis aussi le giro mais très bon pour
la santé et puis aussi on trouve on peut
faire le flanc au jugement la confiture
giraumon la salade de jugement
et puis le port au bo giffaumont on peut
faire tout ça on peut faire la volonté
de jouer au mans on ne fait pas que la
soupe on fait plein de trucs avec le
giro mais qu'est ce qu'une motion raptor
aujourd'hui quand on parle de foire de
gym et ben qu'est-ce que la marche on
attend on attend de la clientèle qu'ils
viennent en masse ou à acheter leurs
jumeaux et parce que les prix sont très
intéressants